L'optimisation classique est une étape cruciale dans les algorithmes classiques-quantiques
comme le solveur variationnel d'eigenstates quantiques ou le machine learning quantique.
Cependant, il s'avère souvent difficile de minimiser
des fonctions complexes dans des espaces de paramètres à haute dimension.
Je m'appelle Victoria Lipinska et dans cette vidéo, on va explorer
les routines d'optimisation classique pour les algorithmes classiques-quantiques.
Les problèmes d'optimisation ne sont pas simples.
Quand le nombre de paramètres augmente, le nombre de combinaisons
de valeurs possibles augmente lui aussi, et ce de façon exponentielle.
Aux échecs, par exemple, il y a 64 cases
et chaque joueur a 16 pièces — après qu'un joueur a déplacé une seule pièce,
il y a 400 positions différentes. Après deux coups, 72 084 positions,
environ 9 millions après trois coups, et environ
280 milliards après quatre coups.
Si on atteint seulement 40 coups, le nombre de positions possibles
est estimé à environ dix à la puissance 120.
Jouer une partie parfaite nécessiterait d'explorer toutes les positions
possibles, et cette croissance colossale signifie que parcourir
toutes les positions une par une est infaisable.
On peut résoudre ça en décomposant le problème en deux sous-problèmes plus petits.
D'abord, on doit déterminer quelles configurations de l'échiquier
sont susceptibles d'apparaître dans les prochaines étapes de la partie.
On appellera ça notre sous-espace d'intérêt.
Et ensuite, à partir de ce sous-espace, on doit déterminer quel coup est le meilleur.
On appellera ça notre meilleur coup.
Dans cette analogie, la recherche initiale dans le sous-espace d'intérêt
correspond à notre algorithme d'optimisation classique.
Une fois ce sous-espace d'intérêt connu,
un algorithme quantique est généralement chargé de trouver le meilleur coup,
étant donné ce sous-espace.
Commençons par considérer un seul paramètre,
theta, qui paramétrise une fonction de coût qu'on veut optimiser.
Si on trace la fonction, disons qu'elle ressemble à quelque chose comme ça,
sur l'axe des x on a les valeurs du paramètre theta
et sur l'axe des y, la fonction de coût.
Garde à l'esprit que la fonction de coût pourrait être un coût financier réel
qu'on veut minimiser, ou comme c'est souvent le cas dans le solveur variationnel
d'eigenstates quantiques, ça pourrait être une énergie minimisée par la nature.
Notre objectif est de trouver le theta
qui correspond au coût le plus bas.
On part d'une valeur initiale de theta et à chaque étape d'optimisation
on trouve un nouveau theta qui diminue encore le coût.
On voit assez facilement dans quelle direction avancer sur le graphe quand on peut le voir.
Mais la difficulté en optimisation, c'est qu'en réalité on ne peut pas.
On ne connaît que le coût — un tout petit morceau du puzzle,
une fois qu'on a évalué la fonction sur le theta choisi.
C'est le fonctionnement général de l'optimisation.
L'optimiseur échantillonne des paramètres theta et calcule le coût.
Comme tu peux l'imaginer, choisir le paramètre theta au hasard pour reconstituer
toute la topologie de la fonction n'est pas très efficace.
À la place, ce que font les optimiseurs intelligents, c'est calculer
le gradient de la fonction à chaque étape.
Ainsi, l'optimiseur sait dans quelle direction aller sur le graphe
pour trouver le coût minimal.
Quand le gradient est nul, l'algorithme s'arrête
et le minimum est trouvé.
Ce minimum n'est peut-être pas le minimum global.
Il peut s'agir d'un minimum local,
c'est-à-dire la plus petite valeur de la fonction de coût dans le voisinage
mais pas sur toute la plage de theta.
Dans le cas d'un paramètre, c'est tout à fait possible.
Cependant, plus on a de paramètres,
plus la fonction devient complexe.
Dès deux paramètres, on obtient une surface,
et avec quatre, on ne peut même plus la représenter.
Tout comme dans l'exemple des échecs, explorer toutes les possibilités
devient vite intraitable.
On voit donc qu'il est difficile de minimiser
des fonctions complexes dans des espaces de paramètres à haute dimension.
Cependant, pour obtenir des résultats raisonnables, on veut que les routines
d'optimisation classique soient à la fois rapides et précises.
Elles doivent aussi être robustes au bruit,
qui aura un effet significatif sur les ordinateurs quantiques à court terme.
Les algorithmes d'optimisation classique peuvent être grossièrement divisés
en deux grandes catégories — la recherche directe et les méthodes basées sur le gradient.
Les méthodes basées sur le gradient nécessitent des informations sur le gradient
de la fonction durant le processus d'optimisation.
Celui-ci peut être calculé analytiquement
ou approximé par un calcul de différences finies.
Les méthodes de recherche directe n'utilisent pas les informations de gradient
et ont recours à d'autres stratégies pour minimiser la fonction de coût.
Certains des algorithmes d'optimisation les plus couramment utilisés
dans le domaine du quantum computing sont les optimiseurs suivants.
COBYLA signifie optimisation sous contraintes par approximation linéaire
et c'est un algorithme d'optimisation sans gradient.
SLSQP correspond à la programmation séquentielle par moindres carrés,
un algorithme d'optimisation basé sur le gradient.
Il utilise un vecteur de perturbation stochastique
pour calculer simultanément un gradient approximatif de la fonction de coût.
Dans un environnement sans bruit, des optimiseurs comme COBYLA
et SLSQP se sont révélés converger plus vite que SPSA.
Les optimiseurs classiques ont leurs propres paramètres
que tu peux spécifier pour des cas particuliers, par exemple, le pas.
Ceux-ci se trouvent généralement dans la documentation relative
à l'optimiseur spécifique.
Je t'encourage à consulter la liste de références ci-dessous pour une comparaison
des optimiseurs classiques les plus récents.
Explorons un autre phénomène lié
à l'optimisation classique des circuits quantiques paramétrés.
Comme on l'a vu, un gradient nul de la fonction de coût peut indiquer
que l'optimiseur s'est retrouvé sur un plateau sans relief particulier — ce qu'on appelle
un « plateau stérile ».
Un plateau stérile peut résulter de nombreux facteurs.
Le gradient de la fonction de coût correspondant à un circuit quantique
avec des paramètres initialisés aléatoirement
décroît exponentiellement vers zéro avec le nombre de qubits.
C'est parce que l'espace quantique exploré par l'optimiseur
devient exponentiellement grand quand le nombre de qubits augmente.
Les façons d'aborder ce problème incluent la réduction du nombre de paramètres
et donc la dimension de l'espace sous-jacent.
Une autre façon d'envisager l'origine du problème des plateaux stériles
pourrait être la nature agnostique du circuit paramétré vis-à-vis du problème,
confronté à un espace de paramètres exponentiellement grand.
Concevoir un circuit de façon adaptée au problème
considéré pourrait être une bonne solution.
En plus de l'espace de paramètres exponentiel qui induit des plateaux stériles,
d'autres phénomènes physiques peuvent aussi en générer :
le bruit et la décohérence présents dans les expériences de quantum computing,
l'expressibilité globale du circuit paramétré,
ou la non-localité et le degré d'intrication de la fonction de coût modélisée.
C'est un domaine de recherche actif que de relever ces défis.
Maintenant qu'on a passé en revue les composantes principales du VQE,
on va résumer l'algorithme dans la prochaine vidéo.